hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
with a really awesome game
from round one of their match magnus
carlsen versus boris girlfriend
and what i really enjoyed about this
game is that they played the exact same
line that
uh magnus already played twice although
he did it with the black pieces and he
defeated both fabiano corona and jordan
van forest with it
but here boris is the one who throws in
a novelty so
we're going to get back to that it's the
it's the line that was played in the
uh wheelchair championship match between
carlson and karwana
uh so most of you probably know it uh
with e4 by magnus
uh sorry about that uh and c5
by boris going for the sicilian defense
knight f3 knife to c6
and d4 we have captures captures and of
course
knight to f6 knight to c3 and here we
have this vesnikov or the pelican or the
alaska variation however you call it
neither d to b5 and
d6 now so i don't know as of uh 2018 uh
a lot of people are also referring to it
as the world chess championship line
uh but okay knight d5 we have knight
captures e captures the knight can go
either to b8 or to e7 magnus
uh so i'm so used to magnus playing this
with black uh that i'm uh
like uh involuntarily saying magnus but
boris goes for knight to e7
and now c4 regarding that the d5 pawn
and
knight the g6 by boris we have queen to
a4
now threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries and the bishop to d7
now uh blocking them and the queen
before now going after this d6 pawn so
the knight can capture it with
check queen to b8 by boris and now h4 we
have
h5 so exactly the same as in the world
chess championship match
uh and the bishop to e3 and here we
reach the position
uh corona had against carlson in the
2018 world championship match it was
game 14
or rather game two of the rapids where
carlson replied with a6 and the magnus
was able to win that game
and also in uh 2019 uh magnus had this
position against von forest in the
tata steel tournament also a6 was played
and also magnus won this
won this game however here again fun
prepares b6 and this is now a new move
so already as of move 13 we have a
completely new game so let's see how
carlson deals with it now
with the white pieces as he's the one
that's
surprised here uh or or maybe he isn't
uh it's
hard to say how much uh how far his uh
knowledge of this
opening line goes uh so uh he continues
with bishop to e2
as the boris is probably gonna develop
that bishop castle and maybe this h5
pawn will be a weakness
with bishop to e7 and here g3 magnus
defends the h4 pawn now with a6 now
finally kicking
the knight back and the knight the c3
i've seen in some lines of the swesnikov
black will want to play e4 at some point
to get the e5 square for his knight even
sometimes at the price of sacrificing
this pawn just to get this knight to
this great outpost
uh but and also maybe why why magnus
decided to develop the bishop to e2 as
it nicely controls these two squares so
maybe preventing such ideas
uh we have b5 now by boris and c
captures on b5 we have a capture sun b5
uh and both players castle now so
castles castles
end here bishop captures on h5 so boris
uh gives up this pawn
for some activity so bishop captures an
h5 by magnus and
bishop to d8 now saying okay if you
capture on g6
i have this very tricky bishop to a5
idea
probably revolving around something that
boris prepared so here if you if you go
for this bishop captures on g6 then
bishop to a5
would be very tricky and requires a lot
of calculation
for example queen moves to b3 bishop
captures b captures and uh or or queen
captures and then f captures and g6
uh leaves the boris with uh the very
strong semi-open f file for the rook the
bishop
now nicely controls the light squares as
white has no light square bishop
and the queen can maybe very easily join
the action also some rook to a for the g
for ids are maybe possible uh boris uh
uh all in all boris knows what he is
doing so after this bishop to d8 move
magnus goes knight to e4 first puts
pressure on the d6 pawn
and here bishop to f5 um boris says i
don't i don't care about the d6 pawn
i'm sacrificing a second pawn so in this
game boris is basically like
mr barnes so of course you cannot
capture with the queen because of bishop
captures here so magnus captures with
the knight
but now bishop to e7 pinning this knight
now there's a double attack here and
magnus has to defend it so he does with
bishop to c5
and now bishop to h3 here
goes after the rook and it's a very very
tricky position
so magnus could just move the rook and
in fact uh it is
what what should be the the strongest
move it is recommended by the engine
rook fc one
uh just getting the rook out of harm's
way and now threatening some discoveries
with the knights to open up uh
a double attack here so for for example
if you let's say play queen to d8 now
you move the knight or capture here
first
captures captures in 94. now with a
double attack here
black can capture and now you have this
position
uh where you have a beautiful past the
d-pawn and you have a two-to-one
advantage uh
here on the on the queen side so you can
very easily create another pass pawn
so this is a one way to go however
magnus decides to play it uh
in great style he plays bishop captures
on g6
so for the moment offering up the the
exchange but not really as uh
you currently cannot capture the rook uh
but what you can do
uh before capturing in g6 is play this
rook to a4 move but rook to a4
is way too complicated for a rapid game
because it
it it just uh uh
offers too much for white for example
knight to f5
white can even offer a full queen here
and now
indeed if you if you capture the queen
then you can just grab the
bishop with check uh king has to go to
h8 and now you're gonna play bishop
captures on b4 and
uh white just has too much material for
example if f captures on g6
you can capture this with check king j8
you can capture this now
and after you grab the rook white will
recapture and you have now two pieces
and rook for a queen
uh which is completely winning for white
so what you could do
after this uh tricky rook a4 idea uh
knight to f5 like we said you cannot go
for the queen you first have to capture
the knight here
and then the queen is hanging so you
have to move the queen and then
something like bishop captures on c5 and
bishop captures
uh here but then black can be very happy
however
like i said rook a4 is not a move a
human would play in a rapid game
so instead after bishop to g6 we have a
f captures on g6 right away by boris and
now comes knight to e4 just opening up a
double attack here
uh if you go for bishop captures on f1
then just bishop captures on e7
with an attack on the rook so boris has
to take care of this we have queen
captures and now bishop captures an f1
boris grabs the rook
rook captures an f1 and now uh now
magnus has this very strong past deep on
uh but you you can see that now he's
down the exchange and in the line that
we've shown where the rook just moves
and goes to c1 we get pretty much the
exact same position with magnus not
being down the exchange
so it's uh uh i mean it's
it's exactly the same the past deepon is
here you can easily create a passport on
the queen side
you're just down the exchange uh but
okay here uh boris has to
decide whether he wants to go upon
grabbing or not let's try uh what
happens if you go pawn grabbing as it
would make sense to get rid of these two
guys
but the d6 and d7 is just too strong for
example captures d7
and it's uh well that pawn is just a
game
winner for example rook d8 you're just
going to go queen c6 defend it and now
let's say go
knight c5 here to to get it away uh also
queen e6
check to be used if black tries to offer
a queen trade or something white
is in full control here so instead after
rook captures an f1 we have queen to see
it boris immediately offers a queen
trade
uh but at the price of this pawn as
boris now wants to start an attack here
on
carlson's king so here we have queen
captures on b5
but now queen to g4 like mr barnes uh
boris only goes forward uh and now
threatening the knight here so here
magnus could play the save queen d3
guard the knight prepared to push the
deep one but magnus plays the very
tricky queen to c4 now threatening some
very nasty discoveries here but also a
knight f6
check would immediately pick up the
queen so
rook to f4 by boris this is a very very
beautiful move
that doesn't really work but it it still
is beautiful
since there is a double attack here you
cannot capture due to the pin
and uh well you're asking just what do
you want to do here if something like
rook to e1 then you play rook to c8 and
you fully mobilize your your pieces as
the queen is nicely defending the rook
you attack the queen and so on however
here magnus finds the very sneaky
d6 check and this uh frees up the d5
square so he can unpin the queen
and he no longer worries about the
knight here so we have king
back to h8 and now queen to d5 not
worrying about the knight
as you're attacking the full rook here
so rook 8 to f8 by boris
uh but now d7 and here here uh you you
can see just how tricky of a position it
is
uh because it's either a winning pawn or
it's an overextended pawn that black can
easily pick up and it really does seem
like
black can do it because the queen
attacks it why not just attack it with
the rook
and that's it but there is a problem
with this and even pause the video
in this uh well position that never
actually happened
and try to figure out the quickest way
to win for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the the
sneakiest idea possible
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to g5
this is how you defend the pawn
indirectly and now
there is nothing more to be done here
because uh well the knight covers these
two squares and that's important and now
if queen goes
for queen captures if you go for this
queen grab
then just queen captures on d7 rook
captures ng captures on f4
of course now the rook is no longer
defended you are up a full piece
or after rook to d8 knight g5 if rook
captures
it's not much better because still
knight covers these two squares just
queen to a8 with
check and now you have to give some
material and then
after all of that it's still checkmate
so this is carlson's idea after the
seven so boris of course
has to accept the knight we have rook
captures and now magnus wins back
material so he brings another queen into
the game
rook captures queen captures with czech
and king to h7 but now
as you can see after all is said and
done magnus is up two connected past
pawns on the queen side and of course he
offers a queen trade so queen d1
boris of course declines he cannot
afford this but now queen to d3
now the rook cannot move so queen g4 uh
gets the queen out of the way that i
hope none of you are
considering f3 now because if you are f3
just leaves the
g3 pawn on unguarded and you will get
checkmated
i'm not saying any of you were thinking
about it uh but just in case
so here magnus pushes h5 and it's a
beautiful move
uh because if queen captures then the
rook falls and of course if pawn
captures then the rook is now pinned uh
the king and queen are on the same
diagonal just rookie one
uh will win the rook here wow those are
weird arrows
uh and so after h5 king h6 by boris but
now comes queen to d2
with check uh we have uh g5 blocking the
check and
now comes queen to d6 check and now what
do you play here
uh if you go back then queen to g6 check
followed by h6 is enough to win the game
so
boris is forced to capture an h5 but now
again the quickest way to victory
i'm sure you'll see it even without
pausing the video why
was magnus so interested in boris
capturing the h5 pawn with the king
i'm just going to congratulate
congratulate everyone for seeing it it's
kink the g2 just free up the h1 square
for the rook
and that's it there's no defending this
uh the queen covers this entire sixth
rank so
the king will have nowhere to go so
boris makes some room for the king on g4
but still rook to h1 check and now if
you go to g4 then it's just a very easy
queen d1 check queen f3 and this is now
checkmate
so boris decided to block with the rook
rook to h4 so
maybe if magnus captures it then the
queen g4
check will give boris some checking
opportunities maybe for a perpetual
however magnus just played queen to d1
with
check and he was in this position on mu
41
that the boris girlfriend resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
uh here after this check you just either
well there's really not much you can do
if king to g6 you just capture the rook
and now the queen covers the g4 square
so there aren't even uh
there aren't even any checks you could
play like maybe one check but
then you can just block with queen to f3
as that's why the queen also comes to d1
and there is nothing more to be done
here so after queen d1 uh
check boris resigns and magnus takes the
win
in the first game of their match so
we'll see what happens in the other
three games uh
could be also very exciting and that's
why i really enjoyed it because magnus
defeated fabi in their wheelchairs
championship match defeated the van
forest
in the tata steel and now defeated boris
girlfriend but
with the white pieces so showing that
the line is deadly with both white and
black pieces but it's uh you know the
the old saying in chess i don't know who
said it but uh i think maybe kasparov
uh in any given position like talking
about theoretical positions uh it's
always the better player
who is better or something in those
lines
uh but yeah once again i do hope you
enjoyed it i would like to thank
uh ross martin uh will rubenstein even
lover of
isaac drum and jocko hans for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the legends
of chess checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your friday